you okay  yeah I'm all right is you crying don't  leave me alone you know I'm watching the  game no I'm not playing I told you they  was gonna lose I don't know why you  acting like this well how's you talking  about my business why is you talking  about my business but they damn bad  what's he points they cheated though  they cheated they cheated they cheated  we would have won they cheated you're  not hot with all that stuff on  yeah  I told you don't when they lose don't  talk to me for the rest of the week why  are you bothering me  dang well what about the wristbands you  act like they finna throw you in a game  and save the last couple of points first  would you leave me alone would you leave  me alone you don't even cry for me like  this I only known you for two months  it's been my team for 22 years  yeah win lose a draw this one